[Music]
the person who was killed by a minor
is why there will be more
minors who will join the
movement but we support the movement
because what is being done is unfair to
the parents who are  able to exercise
their parental authority who does not exercise it
and who lets their kids run
into the street to commit
abuses and who sometimes even take advantage
of these exections then this deserves
to be punished we must put things back
in the right  good order 13 year old kids
they don't have to hang out in the street it's
clear they must be at home
if ever
[Music] [
Music]
my little brother anything in the
street because the street he refused to
temper that is to say we are not
safe we ​​must be safe with
the police we lost it's not normal
[Music]